cher françois fillon mes chers amis
c'est vrai nous l'avons répété depuis ce
matin nous nous réunissons pour la
première fois notre conseil national
après des primaires de la droite et du
centre qui furent un immense succès
démocratique et quelle qu'ait été leur
choix
plus de quatre millions trois cent mille
électeurs ont participé à une démarche
exemplaire et moi aussi je voudrais
saluer le panache de tous les candidats
de la primaire ce panache qui nous
conduit à nous retrouver avec une pensée
particulière pour ceux qui ont présidé
notre mouvement
nicolas sarkozy et alain juppé
avec françois fillon ces électeurs de la
droite et du centre ont fait un choix un
choix de courage
un choix de vérité si toi france soir
qui porte désormais leurs espérances
l'espérance ne peut se réfugier dans le
mensonge
au risque de provoquer la révolte de nos
concitoyens j'ai entendu que la campagne
s'annonce très difficile mais c'est le
lot de toutes les campagnes
nous voilà depuis un mois la cible de
tous les conservatismes
les avocats du statu quo ceux qui
pensent que rien ne doit bouger que le
clientélisme peut faire office de
projets que la défense d'intérêts
particuliers peut suffire à bâtir une
ambition collective ou qu'il faudrait
faire peur mais comment peuvent-ils si
l'avocat du statu quo penser que ce
logiciel soit encore adapté à la
situation de la france
comment comment peuvent-ils se réfugier
dans des caricatures qui vont bon train
entre la disparition de la sécurité
sociale la tête chez risation de
l'économie aussi bien avec vladimir
poutine en vérité quand on n'a ni bilan
ni projet il ne reste que le simplisme
de la pensée et la confiscation des
idées nous ne sommes dupes de rien et
rien ne doit nous détourner du rendez
vous avec les français
car c'est de cela dont il s'agit ce
rendez vous avec la france
c'est le tien françois fillon ça n'est
pas le nôtre c'est le tien ce dialogue
avec les français c'est ce à quoi nous
allons aider à aller mais c'est un
dialogue et je réclame ce dialogue car
pardonnez moi c'est ça le sens profond
de l'élection présidentielle nous sommes
à tes côtés
plus déterminé que jamais à livrer cette
bataille pour le redressement de notre
pays notre famille on l'a vu ce matin et
je remercie
déjà les autres est en ordre de marche
elle réunit des sensibilités ce
rassemblement dans la diversité pour moi
une richesse mais seuls notre union
totale derrière françois peut nous
conduire à la victoire mais je n'ai plus
de doute la primaire consternante elle a
été décrite d'un parti socialiste à bout
de souffle
pris en étau entre jean luc mélenchon et
macron nous conforte comment peuvent-ils
encore prétendre gouverner la france
le premier mélenchon s'époumone à
vouloir incarner la france des ouvriers
celle des travailleurs celle des
insoumis mais c'est france l'a
abandonnée depuis bien longtemps et
souvent et trop souvent pour rejoindre
les sirènes du front national alors
cette france d'un côté mes chers amis à
laquelle nous tenons tant au sénat il
nous appartient à tous de la reconquérir
c'est un combat qui ne doit pas
simplement être le combat de discours
ça doit être un combat village après
village ville après ville département
après département région après région
aucun territoire aucun citoyen ne doit
plus jamais avoir le sentiment d'être
abandonnés ou méprisé alors macron
continue sa marche mais il avait écrit
l'ordre de marche de françois hollande
on connaît les conséquences
le monde change sous nos yeux
nous l'avons vu avec le break site avec
les élections américaines
les états unis vont avoir leur tête dans
moins de cinq jours un président qui
sans doute va bouleverser les schémas
traditionnels la situation au
moyen-orient et tout particulièrement
syrie continue de se dégrader en israël
et dans les territoires palestiniens
nous je reviens les tensions sont ravis
d je ne peux me résoudre à ce que seul
notre pays soit condamné à l'immobilisme
elle n'exerce plus aucune influence sur
la scène internationale
alors mes chers amis que nos soldats
donnent le meilleur d'eux
courage pour lutter contre le terrorisme
les chers amis nous avons trois mois
pour nous battre pour nous battre pour
notre pays nous avons trois mois pour
tourner la page de ce quinquennat des
échecs successifs 6 millions de nos
compatriotes éloignés de l'emploi
pas de croissance et la france qui
poursuit inlassablement depuis près de
cinq ans sa fuite en avant
incapables de dépenser moins incapable
de produire plus incapable d'offrir un
véritable premier emploi un quart de ces
jeunes incapables à moderniser son
modèle social
alors françois re en avant en avant
sorte laissé détourner du chemin que tu
t'es tracé en avant la rencontre de tous
les français
avec le projet que tu portes les
français sont épuisés par trop de
mensonges et de renoncements ton
programme et audacieux ben tant mieux
le refus de l'obstacle capreau souvent
été le mode de gouvernance pour projet
est trop libéral foutaise
l'emploi est au coeur de son projet et
le dialogue social fait partie de ce
projet il serait trop brutal mais la
vraie brutalité c'est le chômage de
longue durée c'est l'échec de
l'insertion des jeunes
c'est près de 9 millions de français qui
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté alors
nous sommes rassemblés autour de toi
françois pour la victoire pour la
république pour la france alors mes
chers amis mes chers amis du conseil
national d'ici mai tous ensemble nous
prenons un seul engagement
on fait tout pour françois fillon pour
la france
[Applaudissements]